M it's
God it's
God what I have to say yeah okay so I'm
a Christian okay so I don't believe that
Jesus is a Muslim obviously because
Muhammad in Islam came 600 years later
after Jesus so I'm saying historically
it literally doesn't make sense to say
that Jesus was a Muslim when Islam came
after so that's my position right but
Muslims say well no Jesus was a Muslim
you know all the prophets were Muslim
and I'm just saying that that doesn't
line up with what history shows us about
these people so that's my that's my
position okay so do you believe Jesus
was the son of God yes okay why because
that's what he says in the gospel in in
the inel The Gospel he says that I am
the Son of God he says that you know um
if you believe in me no one will perish
but you'll have everlasting life and
without believing in me then you have to
face God's Wrath all right so salvation
is in him that's what he says so he says
he's the son of God and he says to prove
it I'm going to die for your sins and
I'm also going to rise again in 3 days
which he did and so because he rose
again it proved everything he said about
himself was true which included being
the Son of God okay so I get that's
that's part of your religion so I can't
argue that we believe that Prophet Isa
Jesus was a prophet for the sole reason
that
we don't believe that he actually did
die on the cross we believe that it was
made to exactly made so plan so honestly
I didn't want to argue with you because
regardless we could talk just just
exchange information I didn't know that
was going to be like a
c camera
shy know going be like a
crowd yeah we believe that he was a
prophet for the sole reason
that you can't have we don't believe
that you can have a son of
God because that means that there God is
a living like fa has a face has hands
has emotions has we don't believe that
we can't say that like God is a figure
like Prophet Muhammad for us peace be
upon him he has no face none of the
prophets Have Faces we don't attach
faces because that means that we're
attaching imperfections God can't
believe that the prophets are are you
said the prophets don't have fa or God
like we you will never see a picture of
Muhammad sah alai wasallam depends on
what depends on what time you go back to
some some of them do have portraits
that's most like offensive thing in our
religion so we W have pictures of
prophet Isa with Jesus we don't have any
pictures of the prophets because that
means that we're attaching imperfections
so let me ask you this so when like so
you have examples where Allah says that
he made Adam with his own hands right
what do you think of that cuz there are
verses where he says he has hands there
are verses where he says you know that
he has eyes that he has a face that he
has a face we know we know that they
have fa they have hair they have no I'm
talking about Allah himself Allah yeah
Allah in the Quran yeah in the Quran
Allah says like you know El right when
he didn't bow down to Adam right so so
Allah says to him why didn't you bow
down to Adam um the one who I made with
both my with my own hands well we
believe that Allah made all of us with
his own hands he made me with his own
hands everything that's right and wrong
with me is made by Allah so you think
it's
metaphoric you could say it's metaphoric
but we personally believe that we can't
put we follow the way of of Jesus of
Muhammad of of all the prophets we
follow their way of life because we
believe that they were
made yes with downfalls because they
were tested but you can't attach a face
to them you can't attach like oh Jesus
has green eyes blue eyes brown eyes you
can't attach that to them because that
means that they also come with
imperfections so do you so do you
believe do you believe that the prophets
themselves are perfect
we believe their way of life is perfect
that to follow Jesus the same way that
you guys follow Jesus we do too we
follow his way impossible yeah we follow
Jesus we follow his way of life you
don't the reason why I say it's
impossible is because you don't you
don't you don't follow what he taught
about himself because you follow him in
the sense of you believe that he died
for your sins that's what he says so you
follow those practices of him but we
follow his way of life of his style like
we also follow the way of Muhammad
pause it cuz what you're saying is
important how do you like where do you
get Jes Jesus's way of life where do you
get that from it's in the in the Quran
he has certain ways of life that we
follow but that's what I'm saying in the
Quran it doesn't give you that in the
Quran I'm trying like his story his way
of life like it tell your neighbor
that's not in the that's not in the
Quran no like his practices his practi
as a Muslim we follow the way of
Muhammad but we also follow the
teachings
ofes that's what I'm saying I know so I
hear I understand what you're saying
you're saying that you I know so you're
saying you follow the way of the
prophets you follow the way of of Isa
Jesus what I'm saying is is that how do
you know that you're following the way
of Jesus when his way is not in the
Quran like you don't find that in the
Quran you find you find the story of
prophet Isa Prophet Isa is Jesus right
so look this is what you get in the
Quran you'll get that he was born of a
virgin you'll get that he spoke from a
cradle you'll get that he created a bird
from clay um and you'll get that you
know he believed that you know in in one
Lord that's it but in the Quran but
there's also and of prophet that's true
but even in these Hadi it doesn't tell
you like it you don't you don't know how
he prayed you don't know what he taught
exactly because
muhamad see he was the last prophet he
taught us how to be a Muslim how to pray
how to fast how to follow the deed
Prophet how do you know if that was the
same how do you know that Muhammad lined
up with what Jesus said we believe I
mean it's just a way like we believe how
like the prophets lived every Hadith of
the Prophet has a story behind it just
like how like you have the stories of
your prophets so so let me ask you this
and just let me know if this makes sense
to you okay if I wanted to know no no
but you're doing good it's like I'm
nervous you're doing de is being
tested you're do you're doing good
you're doing good you got more courage
than a lot of people I'll tell you that
yeah I
didn't okay so tell me if this makes
sense to you okay if I wanted Jesus came
with the gospel right okay Moses came
with the Torah and Muhammed came with
the Quran if I wanted to know what Moses
taught specifically I would go to the
Torah and read it and see what Moses
taught right if I wanted to know what
Jesus taught I would go to the inil the
gospel and see what Jesus taught if I
wanted to know what Muhammad taught I
would go to the Quran and see what God
gave him from the Quran make sense so
that's why I'm asking like so you're
saying that you follow the teachings of
Jesus the way of Jesus where you find
that is in the the in the gospel and so
how do you know that Muhammad's
teachings is in line with the gospel
what Jesus taught in the gospel okay let
me ask you Muhammad s
Alam he had the Quran Islam was the last
religion to come in right is Muhammad in
the in the Bible no okay is Moses in the
Bible yes okay do you know who's in all
three the Quran but in what way just
mentioning them they're all and their
stories are all in the qurans and the
Hadith Islam came last but it has all
the stories of both Moses and Isa and
Jesus okay so like so like for example
how do you know if Jesus taught that he
was the son of God or not how do I know
but it's just the belief in Islam that
we don't have the Son of God because you
cannot right Allah cannot be a person
you understand like it cannot be a
you're saying a human he can't be yeah
he can't be a person he can't look like
me he can't look like you he can't have
the same oh like my hair your hair your
eyes my eyes but this this is this is
where I'm saying like so we don't
believe that when God says that he has a
son that he gave his son that he did it
through like human means or sexual means
or stuff like that right he can he can
have a son of himself without any human
like attributes to him he could just
have a son if he wants to even the Quran
says that like the Quran says if he
wanted to have a son he could you know
but unfortunately the Quran says this
that if Allah were to have a son he
would need a mate so the Quran puts
Allah in this light of of humanity where
he can't have a son unless there was a
mate companion like him that he can have
a son with in the in the gospel in the
Torah it teaches that God can have sons
without a mate he doesn't need a mate or
have these human attributes in order to
have children you know that's why we
don't believe that he he is the son we
can't say that he's the son because
there is no way for Allah to have a m so
like I I got you so now let's go it this
way so in the Quran it teaches Allah
doesn't have a son right in the gospel
Jesus says I am the son right who do I
go
with you a
Christian that's what I was saying like
I understand you got but I have a
question in your belief right you say
that if Jesus died for my sins as long
as I believe that I can go about how I
live as long as I stick to that I can't
I can't do what I want I have to live my
life to Christ I have to live my life to
God it's not it's not a license for me
to go sin and go commit adultery or
murder and stuff like that no of course
no but you have to accept that yes but
in your book as well I've heard tell me
if I'm wrong I'm here I'm here for that
cor me if I'm wrong okay um but I heard
that as long you can do as you you can
do sins but as long as you repent and
accept the word of Christ it's washed
out so it is not that you can do Sins
Not that you can commit sins it's that
when you do commit sins you have Christ
Grace and his Mercy bestowed on you so
once you you turn you commit sin you
turn from that sin God I'm sorry Christ
Grace what he did for you covers it cuz
he took the punishment that we deserve
as Sinners he took the sin upon himself
so yes as long as we have this flesh and
Bone body we're going to do wrong in
this body we're going to commit sin
however we have the work of Christ and
his grace that sets us free from the
wrath of God that we would have to face
if we didn't have him okay does that
make sense yes so that so that's what it
is so um but like in Islam you don't you
don't have that right you have to face
your sins with the law so shoot so like
judment I know right the trumpets are
hored shoot this because of you you
bringing all that but with that being
said like even Muhammad in the Quan he
says I don't know what my Lord is going
to do with me or with you right he
doesn't know but what Jesus says Jesus
says if you believe in me
you will never perish and you won't be
put to shame and I will bring you to
myself he gives us that guarantee so
like to myself I'm like thinking like
who would I rather go with someone who
doesn't know what's going to happen at
the end he doesn't know if I mean even
if I follow him he doesn't know if I'm
going to make it or not or if I follow
Jesus he guarantees me salvation and
guarantees me Paradise with him forever
that's not true there's a Hadith in the
Quran
that says every Prophet was given a Dua
given a wish they could use that Dua for
whatever they wanted but then mammad sah
Al wasallam he didn't use his Dua and
the people were asking Muhammad why
didn't you use your Dua what are you
going to use it for and he
said from my from my from my so on the
day of judgment when everything is
falling apart people are being put into
whether they're going to heaven and hell
Muhammad s Al wasallam is going to say
let my people let my followers make he's
going to use his D to say Let My People
let my followers let my True Believers
come with me to paradise okay and
there's also the fact that in
Islam there's things like a pregnant
mother who loses her child right yeah
that child will go to heaven that mother
even if she
is you looked at me funny I did because
there's a Hadith that there's a Hadith
that doesn't guarantee even babies to go
to heaven like there's it's in sahim
Muslim the book of Destiny it says um
like for example like we would
automatically think a baby innocent go
to heaven straight away that's what the
Bible says that's what you would think
that what I heard that the Bible says
that if that baby is not um what's it
baptized baptized yeah no no no that's
not the Bible no if if a baby dies you
go to heaven really yeah like a child
dies if they're not baptized they don't
go to heaven no no they go to heaven
that's clear the Bible the babies are
innocent not even like I heard like I've
had like Christians like you like very
strong on Christians tell me that if
they're not baptized you don't go to
heaven then they're wrong yeah that's
not Bible that's against the Bible but
in the Hadith uh there's a situation and
a matter of fact I think I can bring
this up if I have a phone yeah yeah go
to sun.com for me really quick I don't
want to just say it I want you to see it
yourself okay is that fair what you
going to say I'll do it thank you so we
go to sun.com it has the
Hadith all right and then um I'm just
going to put in the keyword cuz I kind
of memorize it but not
per Adventure by the way I'm talking
about a miscarriage yeah yeah you're
talking about a miscarriage um like a
child dies a mother carries a child but
it still Burns that child goes to heaven
and even if the mother is destined for
hell that child says I'm in complete
without my without my carrier so on the
day of judgment that mother or whenever
the mother dies that mother will be
destined for heaven just because her
carrier the person that like her baby
needs her okay so like there's things
like that in the Quran as well so
there's things there's shown of like
even if you're Destin for hell there's
exceptions of it there's Allah's Mercy
we have Allah's Mercy you have Jesus
Christ's Mercy we have Allah's Mercy but
I don't I don't see how like just tell
me if this is merciful okay so this Sai
Muslim 2662 see Aisha the mother of the
Believers said that Allah's messenger
peace be upon him was called to lead a
funeral prayer of a child of the onsa so
a child died I said so this is Aisha
speaking Allah's messenger there is
happiness for this child who is a bird
from the birds of paradise for it
committed no sin nor has he reached the
age where one can commit sin now
obviously that's like yeah baby can't
commit sin he didn't reach the age he
commit sin he goes to heaven straight
away right so this is what Muhammad
responds with um he said Aisha per
Adventure like hold on stop it it may be
otherwise because God created for
Paradise those who are fit for it while
they were yet in their father's loins
and created for hell those who are to go
to hell he created them for hell while
they were yet in their father's Lo so
he's basically saying it's possible that
this baby this child who died is going
to is going to hell because Allah
created them for hell even if they
didn't do anything wrong so that's my
problem with this okay so we already
believe that where whether before were
ever born Allah wrote In the book like
you're going to hell you're going to
heaven this is who you're marrying this
is who your brother is this is who your
sisters this is the job you're going to
have yeah you can with Dua we call it
Faith change your what if you did
already so if a baby dies let's say that
baby was written for hell but in his he
died what did he do to go to hell he
didn't do anything nothing he just
created for him right so it's destined
but your c will change so your your
faith will change but how the baby
doesn't have faith it doesn't the baby
okay but I'm saying within the baby's
Faith the mother can make Dua for for of
a child the of their child can be
changed through the mother's Dua through
their prayer I don't think that there's
a cuz cuz even with Muhammad's like
Muhammad asked for Allah to save his
parents like for his mother and his
father but Allah said no right even even
Muhammad asked for his mom and his dad
to be led into Paradise because they
were pagans
and he said no yeah they right so even
with Muhammad's faith and he's the
prophet even with his
supplication they they didn't get into
to Paradise yeah so this is like
something that's not because his father
was his parents were pagans right so you
can change your color it's not going to
be guaranteed that you're going to
change your color but the thought
process of Islam is
just if a child dies right and they were
written for hell if they were to live
their full life but they were written
for hell but they died
they died before they even had a chance
to open their eyes yeah a mother's Dua
will change that child's G for sure yeah
cuz you said it's not always guaranteed
so what if in the example that the baby
dies and Allah doesn't accept the
mother's supplication and just sends the
baby to hell as it was destined
already but that's the thing the child
didn't do anything wrong for it to be
you could change your like for example
if you converted right you changing your
you repentant you change your but let's
say
I'm not saying you are I definitely am
not saying you are you were destined for
hell let's say no no no no say but let's
say you were destined for hell you
changed your C you repented you came to
Islam that gets erased but in Islam we
also believe you are going to pay for
the sins but you will end up in heaven
regardless how would you pay for your
sins everybody's going to spend their
time to pay for their sins in yes
everybody's going to every Muslim is
going to hell for at least a little time
no
for the ones who went without repentance
are going to pay for what they didn't
repent for it's like if a bank lent you
money and you didn't pay for it back
you're going to have to keep paying
until you pay for it back so yeah my
question is how how does a person on
Judgment Day pay for their sins and so
that they can get to heaven if their
sins if their sins versus their rewards
were equalized like let's say let's say
the let's say the bad Deeds are right
they didn't repent for this half yeah
they're going to have to pay for that
half but regardless after they do they
go to heaven so that that's what I'm
asking how do they pay for that half
in hell I'm not going to lie to you like
good so you're saying so really so every
Muslim has sins that they have to pay
for right right without repentance yes
right so there's going to be some sins
that every Muslim has that they have not
repented for all right and so they're
going to have to do some time in hell to
make up for and pay for it so every
Muslim is going to do some time in here
whether it's a day whether it's a year
two years some every Muslim is going to
face
Hellfire if they're five no without if
they five you know how there's five
pillars of Islam if they do not
equivalate out you didn't pray but you
fasted but you you made you did H but
you didn't pray you didn't whatever if
they don't equal out with your rewards
yes you do time in he in Hell how do you
see and and see now now this is the
problem so you're going to you're most
likely going to do time in
hell and then in vers verses where Jesus
says I did the time for you I put your
sins upon myself and I paid it for you
so where do your sins go it's on him on
the cross okay but when you still commit
sins as you believe in Jesus on the
cross it's it's dead and gone on the
even my future sins that I that I commit
even my future sins that I commit on the
cross Jesus Paid It All for all time so
what I have to do is trust in him for my
salvation and even when I do wrong I
turn back and I look back to the cross
and what he did he did it for me so
anytime you turn back to the cross I
turn back to Christ it Chang you're
automat you're guaranteed I'm cleansed
his righteousness is imputed unto me
it's given to me but see now that sounds
like I can give all hell's way as long
as I turn back to the Cross well no see
there's a difference the difference is
intention right if I'm doing if I'm
living in sin like living practic
practicing sin doing sin intentionally
right over over then I'm a I'm a false
believer I'm a hypocrite that's what I'm
that's what I was trying to say if you
are intentionally committing s like if I
smoked right and I kept smoking kept
smoking kept reping kept smoking kept
right that's a false repentance that's a
false repentance that's what I'm saying
we're paying for yeah okay so you're
saying that you're paying for a false
you know continuing knowingly sinning
openly sinning showing your sin sorry no
no you're fine openly sinning yeah so
you're going to do time in hell for
openly sinning right because false
repentance yeah for false repentance for
hypocrisy all that kind of stuff and so
you're going to do time in hell all of
you while you have Jesus who says you
don't have to do that I did it for you
but see how does that come that's the
thing you're not living it's a way of
like a way of your lifestyle you're not
living in a way of
fearing the afterlife we believe that
this life is temporary right it's all
temporary it's not like everything that
happens here does not matter not not
that it doesn't matter like yeah it's
very temporary cuz the afterlife is more
beautiful yes so we live on the style of
life but it sounds like you you can't
you have nothing to fear from because
you can just keep repenting going to go
to so this is what this is what it is
you're right I don't have to fear the
Hereafter because my Pro My Hope Is In
Christ and he promises me an end right
with him as I as long as I trust in him
for my salvation but my faith in him I
have nothing to fear that's literally
what he says he says come to me all of
you who are heavy laden I will give you
rest for your souls I will leave give
you peace not as the world gives but my
peace is eternal so I in this world can
have peace because I have a hope that I
know is guaranteed for me now instead of
fearing what's going to happen with me
now I don't here's the here's the part
though the the way that I live my life
in is to Christ and doing good and
things things of this nature is not
because I'm fearing Hellfire but it's
because I'm thank ful that he paid for
my sins I'm I'm living a life of
gratitude so that's why I don't sin and
I turn away from you know pornography or
I turn away from adultery is because I
love Christ and I love and I'm grateful
for what he did for me so I don't want
to spit in his face by rejecting him and
going and sinning again when he died for
my sins so we have that sense of
gratitude in our religion too by the way
like we we're not living dayto day
because like oh we're we fear Allah yes
that is true but we also love him for
his Mercy because he was merciful on us
he should regardless of the fact Allah
will always show you Mercy is that Mercy
the
babies okay hold on can you open it I
like how you have your I have mine
thanks SEC do do you do you think it's
merciful to create someone for hell
before they even do anything I just want
to point out also it's a proven fact
that a lot of the words in Arabic will
not be truly translated English in
English because there's over 60,000
words and they cannot all be completely
transl but but we do we do check
this oh I'm a Muslim girl and it's my
curfew oh okay time to go well short
like no I I you know I would give you a
air hug and a and a you know shake can
you give that I can't touch you but can
you give me
one I got
you honestly I again I'm not like a
hijab but I know midle you got some
knowledge I'll give you that the fact
that you quoted a Hadith a lot of people
can't do that you got some knowledge
it's really good there's more people
around here who know a million times
more than me who will actually be able
to prove a lot more cuz I guarantee you
that there's not I've been sitting here
all night you've given me the most
logical conversation I've had yet you
know so um but yeah you guys got to go
but look think about what we talked
about have you ever read the gospel
before you have you have you have Bible
no my friends just your friends okay
like exchang for sure all right look
look it some more okay look it some more
you guys got to go take care thank you
for the conversation hey
guys oh my godic
[Music]
oh